hello everyone
welcome to collider for some sundance
2021 coverage
i am beyond thrilled right now to have
the team behind how it ends
with us right now daryl zoey kelly
welcome to the channel and thank you
guys so much for swinging by to talk
about your movie
thanks for having us yeah all right
so to start here the beautiful thing
about a festival is
that everybody is hearing about your
movie for the very first time but that
means i need someone to give a synopsis
so
zoey daryl who wants to go for it what
is how it ends about
here i can do it so how it ends is about
a woman played by
zoe who goes on a journey across the
city of l.a on the last day on earth
to make it to her last party before the
world
ends and runs into an eclectic
cast of characters along the way
okay i was also trying to figure out
where i should stop
in my line of questions i noticed a
couple things weren't included in the
in the production notes
all right so was this idea born
from the pandemic or were any of these
themes and ideas that we see on display
here ones that you two were toying
around with and eager to explore through
film before
i think they were almost entirely born
out of the pandemic
um i mean the themes of like sort of
inner child work and wrestling with
um one's own sort of
um fears and vulnerabilities is
obviously timeless
but um i think the pandemic is what
spawned our desire to really tackle them
head-on enough film that's hard
i'll take her you can talk but um
yeah i think we started writing it we
started we started conceiving of it
like a couple months into lockdown um
and we were conceiving of it
also that's our talk um we were
conceiving of it
also um with
with the um idea in mind that we wanted
to be
going into production in during the
pandemic um
so part of its conception was also
figuring out a narrative that worked
within the parameters of
um you know the kobe 19 safety protocols
and we sort of went
the extra uh mile and shot it all
outside and six feet apart
um but yeah it was um
fully a pandemic um pandemic production
production
there's something that i love about the
film feeling like it's going to be a
little bit of a time capsule of this
unique time that we're all struggling
through right now so i definitely
appreciate that part of it
kelly what was your first reaction when
they called you up about this project
one did you have a clear vision of what
they wanted to do
right from the initial description and
then two i mean did you have any
apprehension about shooting a movie in
covid times um
well zoe was in my
quarantine pod when the lockdown started
so
she was very much in my world we were
going on
a six feet apart walks and that was kind
of the only thing
keeping me sane at the moment she was i
did have a professional therapist
but she was actually more helpful at the
time um
for me um she uh she's my guru
um so we were
you know she we both hinted at doing
something creative
in this time and then it was so crazy
and i mean
it's not crazy to us because we are our
minds are always synced up it feels like
but
i texted her saying hey i think we
should
make a movie and daryl and zoe
were right in the middle of planning
something out and sketching a storyline
together
so um i think my only apprehension was
um diving into the world of comedy
um which they i mean daryl and zoe
the films that they made previously they
they balance
comedy and drama so beautifully i've
actually never seen
it done the way they do it so i had a
sort of
idea i just didn't know how i was gonna
pull it off at all and they
were so great and they let me play and
find where i needed to be like the first
day was literally just
trying to help kaylee figure out what
the tone of this film was but i think we
got there and we had so much fun along
the way
with that in mind having gone through
your first experience doing comedy is
there any
i guess a new tool in your acting
toolkit so to speak that even when we're
filming things normally again
you know came from your experience
for sure i i never felt so free
i mean what was so beautiful about doing
this is that zoe and daryl
were very much like wherever you're at
today
because it was such un i mean
unprecedented times that we were in and
still
are they or so understanding that you
know if you're waking up and you're in
your pjs and you don't know how you're
gonna get through the rest of the day or
you know if you wanna throw a tantrum if
you wanna cry in the scene if you wanna
laugh hysterically like
what wherever you you're at in your life
it works
for today it works in the scene and
we're just going to use it
so um i i think that'll
hopefully um serve me in my
um projects to come because it just like
what
whatever you wherever you're
at to start with when you came to set um
was you know like there was there was no
issue
in they just like it was so full play i
felt like i was going back to the
root of what this is for me so
um it was very refreshing and nourishing
zoe and daryl given how kelly just
described the experience how did you go
about
writing a script for this and then
assembling your ensemble too is it a
situation where
you kind of need to wait until you have
all the pieces
in place to really write out every
single scene or
did you have the blueprints and then
just fit people into it
we kind of knew like after we conceived
of it what we wanted to do
and started with a structured outline
and then wrote out a lot of it
and then left some as
like frameworks with structured story
beats for the actors to be able to hit
so for example like all of kaylee and
zoe's scenes are fully written and helen
hunt and zoe
and bradley whitford and zoe are
scripted
for example and then there's tons of
scenes also that
are working off of this
creative outline that has these moments
that
and in some cases even dialogue that we
knew we wanted the actors to hit
and we did have a lot of those actors in
mind
like who we wanted to work with and
just fortunately a bunch of them are
people that we've either worked with
before or
their friends um luckily and
they didn't have a lot to do because it
was been you know the pandemic so
we just reached out and said hey are you
interested in
in getting back out there and maybe
making something
and so many of them were like yes let's
go
and some were a little scared and and so
it was it was
it was really fluid and and malleable
based on kind of where they were at
you assembled such an incredible group
of uh talented individuals here so i
imagine this applies to everyone to a
degree but if you had to pick one
cast member who i don't know just really
surprised you
threw you a curveball took an especially
big swing that panned out
and is in the movie now who would you uh
want to highlight
it's impossible to highlight one over
another because we have such an
embarrassment of riches and
everybody is absolutely incredible
my choice will be kelly spaney yeah
it's true because she
i think really we did we did kind of
drop her into the deep end with the
likes of
people like fred armisen and and
nick kroll and and um and
she swam she
was so fearless even though she likes to
think that she was full of fear which i
know
there was some trepidation but but she
is just so effortless and and so
authentic
in her choices and such a cute little
nugget
and um and just such a such a
talented actress and so i i was so
so blessed as co-director to to get
to work with kaylee who i had only seen
and heard about through zoe from the
craft
and seen her other work um and she was
just such a joy to work with because she
was so down for anything
and there's you know throughout in this
business
some actors can be more difficult than
others
um and kaylee was just so free
um and open to do whatever we kind of
threw at her
kellie i've got a i got a two-parter for
you
having brought up the craft and worked
having worked with zoe onto just
extremely
different types of material and also
ways of filming what's one thing that
you love that she did
as a leader on set on the craft that
carried over to this
and then what's a new side of her as a
creative
that really kind of popped out and was
shining to you on the set
oh i mean it was it was so incredible
to work with her creatively in such
different ways back to back
her being my leader and my director
which she did so effortlessly like
literally like there was i always felt
peace when i was on set with her like
she
she just was such a guiding light for me
and it was such it was scary the first
time i've ever led a movie like that and
she
um you know really held my hand
throughout that whole thing so to see
her
like like i mean she she was my
she was my director you know she she
really
had such grace when she was um
leading that ship and then to get to act
with her
was also such a dream and i'm such a fan
of her
performance and and band-aid and
breaking upwards
i just i i couldn't wait to
get in there and and do those scenes
with her and
she just blows my mind every time i
watch her the way that she can
she can improvise in comedy so
effortlessly
and then snap into a dramatic scene just
like that it was just
i mean it it was i'm feel so lucky to
to get to well first of all to be your
friend but also to
to to just just soak in all your genius
you know
so but we filmed we filmed two
movies back to we had two like we
were non-stop it was insane like that's
a bond that'll never be broken
yeah i know i'm gonna be stealing okay
i'm gonna be really jealous when kaylee
goes and makes
a thousand other movies with other
people
because uh yeah 2020 2021 has been
the year of kelly spain clj thank you
for saying all of that makes me cry and
i love you so much
i love you too speaking of
going on to make other movies callie and
i guess you might have touched on this
before with another answer you gave me
but
you know looking back at your resume
since you know
bursting onto the scene with pacific rim
uprising i think almost all of your
films have been like
big major productions and now you're
doing something more
intimate like this so what is a part of
the filmmaking process on a smaller more
intimate movie like how it ends that
you're going to bring
back with you when you do get another
blockbuster lead
i think um it's just the play of it all
like when you're
when you're a kid and you go outside and
you play pretend with your friends or
you're
you know you're making um films in your
backyard or whatever it is wherever that
love
for the art started for you um i really
found that again on this project
you know there was no pressure at all it
was completely
play and um just just
joy you know and there's no wrong answer
i think sometimes when you do
those big studio films there's a lot of
pressure because there's a lot of eyes
on you
um there's a lot at stake and um
you know i had no idea where this was
gonna go and then the
stat the cast came out i'm like oh
this is this is a real this is a real
deal right now and now we're at sundance
but
i could have never imagined it you know
we weren't thinking that far or at least
i wasn't i'm sure you guys
knew you were making gold but um
yeah i that that's what i hope to bring
on to the next projects
okay it's just the love for it we
actually have like
50 studio executives on zoom watching
i love hearing that she had a no
pressure experience but as the
co-directors as the two
steering this ship what is kind of maybe
like a little thing that is viewers we
wouldn't pick up on
that has challenged you for the first
time basically wearing a million and one
hats on this production
well it's the first time that we've ever
co-directed um we've
made a number of films as co-writers and
co-producers
um but yeah so that was i wouldn't say
that that was a challenge i think you
know
it sort of came organically especially
because of quarantine
um and the nature of the film but um
yeah this was probably i mean breaking
upwards was our first film
and we wore a thousand and one hats on
that
but we hadn't gone um back to wearing
quite as many hats until
um returning to how it ends so
um yeah i think that was probably the
biggest challenge i mean outside of
obviously
coveted safety protocol challenges um
i think it was really just sort of we
were such a lean
crew um daryl was lensing the film he
was operating
um and and then we were co-directing we
were both writing we were both directing
i was acting
producing producing we had no a.d or
um daryl had no camera department i mean
he had a co-dp but um there was no focus
puller or ac's that we had no
um costume designer no hair and makeup
we we had we had no supervisor
um so you know we were very much like
in charge of just making sure that um
that we were getting the things we
needed and that um
yeah i think that that was probably this
those were the stakes and i think the
the other stakes i'm such a um i think
daryl is too but i
i take it to like sort of almost a
problematic level
of like i'm so concerned with people's
um
level of comfort and and
um well-being on a set um that like
asking this ask was even bigger than
asking someone to do an indie with you
because um this was the first time that
so many of our cast members had
acted or or performed at all or been
creative since lockdown
so um so there was just like those
nerves of making sure that like
these you know huge actors that we were
asking to come do this sort of
experimental project with us
were um you know feeling like they were
getting a fulfilling experience
and not um you know freaked out i mean
it
i think it helped that each of them were
paid a million dollars each
you know i mean that was pretty sweet
deal yeah oh for what it's worth i am a
firm believer that more people out there
should be taking that part of
production that seriously so i
appreciate that you do that
just so we can kind of shout out some
other members of the ensemble and i can
ask about like little details here a
bunch of
very random questions that might seem
you know kind of silly but first
who made the pancakes at the beginning
of the film because they look real good
and they made me want pancakes
those came from ihop
shout outs oh my god
i'm obviously gonna grab her ihop later
another food question for you did olivia
wilde
personally select that specific end of
the world cake
no she did not i did that was my
dream end of worlds meal however she
happily enjoyed it and definitely ate
some of that cake
now i need more specifics it's your
dream end of world meal
like what specific where did the cake
come from like a chocolate oreo
yeah luscious like
multi-layered multi-layered chocolate uh
cream all the dairy that you can
consume i very much respect that choice
zoe and kaylee what is your
end of world meal of choice but wasn't
that cake what would it be
so he's definitely all-time all-time
dressing
dressing there's a restaurant in la
that has this is so sad though my end of
world meal is not a salad
i just need to say that no it can't be
it can't be but um
but i did eat a lot of this like
dressing that i don't know what is in it
but it's like it's like it tastes like
ice cream
in a dressing form um and so it makes
salads like
somehow like a treat um
but uh end of world
meal i'm sure it'd be pasta for you no
yeah like like a pasta pizza
it would just be yeah like caramel
loading
yeah the best so i'm behind that yeah
i think mine would be chicken and
dumplings preferably from cracker barrel
just because i'm from
the southern midwest that's all i can
think about easy hash browns
and a breed and a burrito
yeah yeah kaley would come to set almost
every morning
having eaten she'd be like oh i don't
feel great we'd be like what'd you eat
i'm just
like a burrito and we're always like
maybe that's the
the kicker is that that's not sitting
well everywhere the amount of times that
happened was so sad
yeah i got the nickname as little
burrito on set
yeah as long as the burrito's worth it
it's all good in my book
always worth it so i know there's a
certain restrictions that we have to
abide by now but did any of you get to
pet
logan marshall green's puppies yes
they were super cute and when he brought
them to our house
they pooped all over the backyard but
because they're so cute it was okay
they're called chugs they're chihuahua
pugs chugs
and those were his actual quarantine
like emotional support
purchases or i think he adopted them but
yeah um
that was like legit in terms of like
kaylee saying people just like showing
up where they're at like
that is literally how logan showed up
like i've got
i've got three chugs can i bring those
i feel like that's gonna be an
expectation going forward like now he
just can't
show up to a new set without two chugs
in his arms yeah
it's in his contract yeah uh zoe how
much do you hate those shoes now
i burned them um they
yeah i decided to wear them on the first
day and then cursed
myself and everyone around me every day
thereafter
um it was really ridiculous i was a
ridiculous person
talking about those shoes the shoes are
definitely a character in the film
and there was so much hill walking but i
think like both of us
got a good like good like glute butt
workout as a for sure
as a bonus it's a solid silver lining
there
yeah um i have to let you guys go soon
but
i kind of wanted to wrap up with a big
question all three of you could feel
free to weigh in on this
but i feel like this is an important
thing to keep highlighting you could
probably sense that i like talking about
this at this point but
one of my favorite aspects about the
movie is that i feel like it shines a
major spotlight
on the value of long-standing
collaborations and
i imagine you always want to be open to
meeting new filmmakers out there
but why is continued collaborations and
continuing to build them
important to the work that all of you
want to do this business
is such a tough one and
you know you can sometimes feel like you
have lost your rudder
there's so many forces and external
factors and
i think that for me zoe has
always kind of been there as a very
grounding
presence and kind of
been this incredible life partner but
lula's like what about me
problem oh my god
um and uh
i mean we started off in this business
working on stuff together
uh our first movie breaking up words was
11 years ago now and we've done stuff
separately
but i always feel safest when i'm
working with zoe
um really because we share
such a similar sensibility and taste
and she's so dang smart
and uh i just we complement each other
really well
um and so it's just always lovely to
collaborate and bounce ideas off of each
other
and that's rare to find sometimes in
this business sometimes you meet someone
on a project that
you never get to work with again um so
to foster a
relationship over time as zoe and kaylee
have started to do on the craft
and we've done over many years is is is
really special and
i'm very grateful to continue to make
work with zoe
thanks t no
that was so beautifully said and thank
you so much and i uh
echo it all in in return yeah i mean
it is amazing to um daryl just had all
of our movies actually
um printed i'll show you what can i show
you yeah sure printed on um
on vhs um uh
boxes well yeah they're like i don't
know if you can see
but like oh so there's a band-aid on vhs
and then here's um the craft
on vhs well this guy made them online
they're really cool
and then he got howard ends made on vhs
but we have like
we have so many um that we've made
together uh
whether it's been you know him producing
something that i've directed or me
producing something
he's directed or us writing together and
it is amazing to have
um you know all of those filmmaking
experiences
um under our belts as a as a team um
and i and i yeah echo all of the
sentiments that it is so nice to have
that um sort of shared sensibility in an
unspoken language um that i think made
how it ends um all the
like more fluid a process because um
we can just sort of pick up uh what the
other is looking for
without um without even having to say
anything a lot of the time
um and then like in addition to
our collaborations you know it was
amazing to then have kaylee
um come on board after we had just
worked together on the craft and
um and to yeah be fostering this
this relationship both creatively and um
personally is so special and moving um
and then really the whole cast too i
think like
i i have worked with almost all of them
um before how it ends and and
consider so many of them friends and i
think like daryl said like this is such
a
a brutal business in so many ways and
and so to be able to
sorry one sec um
anyway that's a wrap will you grab the
door no i'm sorry there's someone at our
door
i i was just gonna say yeah it's just so
lovely to be able to
contact lula to be able to continue
working with um
with people that you hi sorry we're in
an interview brian will you just give us
one
second
this is a full nightmare um i've hit
your situation
many times i get it
uh yeah it's just it's it's um it's it
i just feel so lucky to
to have a dog that is so vocal i feel so
lucky
kelly yes
i mean i i was just gonna add that for
every actor i think it's the dream to
find that
director actor collaboration you know i
think it's so hard to
put yourself out there and be vulnerable
as an artist
and um when you find that special person
that you
can just click with and likes always
said like the minimal
um amount of talking the minimal amount
of explaining like
you know you can look at the person and
they know exactly what you're gonna do
and vice versa i think
yeah i just think it makes the
experience better
um which we all want and i at the end of
the day i think it makes art better as
well
um so yeah and i just feel so lucky that
um i've connected with you you two both
and um i hope that we keep making films
forever
i'm all for that i feel like you can
feel it coming through in the movie and
you guys
you have a one-two punch here of tapping
into things that i think many out there
have experienced over the past
year now and then on top of that
when our industry is being rocked to the
core
by something like a pandemic the fact
that you could feel the passion for
filmmaking and just the willingness to
do whatever you need to do in order to
keep delivering content
that's meaningful right now that in and
of itself is very meaningful to me and i
know a lot of people watching this
interview share that same feeling so
thank you for bringing how it ends to
sundance and
huge congratulations to everybody out
there do keep an eye out for it
how it ends thank you so much thank you